In this Sprouts Teaching Technique
we introduce the idea of “Student Leaders”,
a simple task based method teachers can use to build self-esteem,
teach responsibility and help students take
pride in themselves and their classroom.
To create your own student leaders,
think about activities that your students can help you complete.
Watering plants,
being in charge of getting you books
or anything that is easy for them to do
and makes them feel special.
Next, transform these tasks
into special roles for your students.
Instead of just having your students water your plants,
give them the title of “Rain-Maker.”
Instead of getting a book,
name them the “Book-Master”.
Giving these tasks a title will make them excited to help you.
It will also help them pay attention
and feel good about themselves.
Some tasks can be daily and some every few days.
It helps to create a “Student Leader”
calendar for all your students to see
and make sure that you rotate through the tasks
and that everyone gets a turn at every task.
Please use the comments below
to let us know what you think!
If you are a student,
tell us if you’ve ever been a student leader.
If you are a teacher,
share your tips on how to use this in your classroom.
We’re releasing updates regularly,
so don’t forget to subscribe to our channel.
Thank you for watching!